der trickdieb in bali verantwortlich für
das ressort
[Musik]
zu meiner tätigkeiten darunter zum
beispiel planen vom kongo ist
versorgungsformen geräte
personentransport
und eben verschiedenste
instandsetzungsmaßnahmen beziehungsweise
den erhalt von der betriebsfähigkeit der
fahrzeuge
[Musik]
christen schwierigkeiten beim
straßenverkehr sind
das da unten die lokalen die lokale
presse verkehrslage mit unbedingt so
irgendwann wird das kann sich doch jeder
mit ein bisschen geld da muss man sich
gar für eine tombola türen geöffnet und
dementsprechend dieses verhalten
skurrilste wo sie doch runden erlebt es
gibt es ja viele skurrile situationen zb
dass man drei ziegen auf ein moped
transportiert zwar auf ein
lkw piloten bis fünf sechs sieben meter
über über normalniveau also es ist für
europäische augen sehr
interessant